if you notice nothing about Breakfast at
Tiffany's oh whatever never they'll
never fix that that's okay to take
people's eyes back Mickey Rooney right
yeah yeah
I was like oh yeah that guy's Asian that
put us forward because people still
think that's an Asian guy what's the
name of The Walking Dead porno that they
spoofed and then they couldn't find an
Asian porn why are you asking us like
they got a white guy they kicked his
eyes back don't worry I got this one no
glamor pull your dick away dude you just
put us on game and you you acted like
we're all supposed to know
good I did I'm sorry sorry my bad
Walking Dead you don't think it's a deep
cut a kickboxer you know tongpo is
actually Armenian really oh yeah that's
cool
that's cool he's actually in that side
they taped back Tom clothes eyeballs now
that you say that Remo Williams his
master was Korean but he was a white
played by white guy and they kept his
eyes back and they put all his makeup on
and it was so good nobody knew just wait
guys like 56 years from now maybe we'll
be a white guy and no one will know